some of my friends like yo
i told a couple like my close friends
that was what i was doing today like yo
you're not going to be embarrassed i'm
like bro i'm like ah
what did this day and age if you fought
the whole world knows it who the [ __ ]
has you know
there is no hiding anything this day and
age with the internet nothing well the
secrets i think are more damaging than
uh
okay
the opinion of the opiate the opiate
opiates have taken over the world i'm
far from the only one
i'm just very faithful that i never got
to the point where i had to you know
inject i never ever have done that there
are times i've been sick and i've been
offered that and i refuse to do it
all right joe so tell me tell me about
uh talk about your gambling i guess that
was very yeah i still my father was my
father used to bed football on the
weekends so you know as he following my
false footsteps i started betting with a
bookie little by little and you know i
was winning i'd win i'd win i'd win some
small losses then eventually i started
i'm like well i'm always winning why not
bet more money so i started betting more
and more and you're making money with it
yeah yeah
every week i'd meet the bookie he'd give
me you know the runner he'd give me
maybe like 700 one week uh 1200 the next
week make 400 one other week so i
started obviously in time i started
spending money got a new truck and i
started eventually betting more and more
uh unfortunately after winning like 12
weeks in a row where i had built up a
nice little nest egg i lost like this
was 2003. i had lost like
21 years old and i lost like 36 thousand
dollars
at this point i've been buying things as
i'm going along i maybe i had about i
don't know about
1500 to my name at that point when i
lost all this in one week
so i did what anybody else did in my age
then before i told my parents i head out
i ran
i thought when i finally went back to my
house to uh tell my parents what's going
on
the two bookies caught me running into
my house and they dragged me in the
driveway and
the uh the guy in charge put the gun
right in my mouth i just [ __ ] laughed
right in his face i said you shoot me
you ain't get a dollar so go right ahead
so of course that didn't take too kindly
to that but then my mother
pulled in the driveway to the house
and they uh calmly took off my mom was
like oh my mom's like who's them i got
your hopes witnesses don't worry about
it well my growing address that i
unfortunately went in the house and told
her what my hub would happen and uh
my father had to take a 401k uh loan for
his pension
to pay it off and he did and i paid him
back over a few months after bet and
sports and poker again it just i
couldn't keep it as an addiction like
anything else
you learned it from your dad yeah
but so in general you were making money
or losing yeah i was making no see
that's the thing i would i would win
let's say i would win eight out of ten
weeks but the one the weeks i'd lose i'd
really think oh something's wrong i'm
gonna catch up i'd go for it you know
what i mean
so i wouldn't maybe any i would average
my average win might be a thousand a
week but the weeks i lose i'd lose six
thousand
you know what i mean so yeah i was
winning 80 of my weeks but the math
admit the math was like didn't add up
right how long did this go on
uh probably until after the world series
of poker prior to like
2006 seven out of dims a lull then i
started again and probably like i said
the last time i bet was basically my
father died
that was after that i kind of said you
know what i'm not gonna bet sports no
more and i'm not going to drink any
liquor anymore because my father drank
himself and died so you got into poker
yeah paul pogba i started playing in
junky with sports betting but polka is a
little better is a better way to gamble
because you're playing against the
players not against you know you know i
think i'm in control of what happens you
know i mean to a certain extent you know
the cards are involved but the poker is
the one game that you know player has a
chance because it's based on your skill
also with some some luck
in sports betting you have no prayer of
what happened you know you have no
control right no control of the outcome
exactly so poker had a little more how
far did you take the poker poker i took
it to basically the highest level there
is the biggest tournament in the world
is the the main event of the world
series of poker it's a 10 000 entry fee
in 2005 i'd been playing for the past
couple years after the after the
incident with the bookies i played for a
couple years in underground clubs in
union square uh i played the towns up
uptown ace point 64th street
uh union square was called playstation
which was the biggest club in the city i
started earning good money i had me and
i had a partner at the time
and we started earning money and finally
i went out to the world series of poker
in 2005 and
i played a smaller tournament to win a
seat into the bigger tournament in which
i did and i turned that you know i
started playing and then after day one i
had a big i had a nice chip stack and
sports illustrated an article about me
it was titled beauty and the beast
because they did a full feature on me
and uh the actress shannon elizabeth she
was sitting right near me at the time
and she made it through day one as well
so basically they were saying because
i'm like you know a big hideous man and
that she's a beautiful actress you know
so that was the article they did on so
like it was embarrassing to see the
title i was like oh my [ __ ] god but
like i said it got me exposure a little
by little espn followed me i made it i
made it you know into day six i played
through five days of poker and uh i made
a great run and made my name in the
poker world that way
a lot of exposure on espn for weeks and
weeks on end
tell me about that lifestyle
it's a lot of it's great people think
it's easy it's a it's an easy way to
make a hard living because it is it's
it's
a mental grind you know you're not gonna
tear an acl like you're playing but it's
a professional sport and it's just you
have to be so sharp people don't realize
that during the world series of poker i
like i started playing at 11 a.m the day
would start you play till 2 am 15 hours
straight to poker every day and at the
end of the day you realize you're
playing first place is 7.5 million it's
hard to get to sleep at night knowing
you're playing for that but the same
time you have to rest you have to rest
because
it's because you have to be into the
shop the next day 15 hours again for 18
hours again the drain on your central
nervous system yeah exactly i was
drinking like i was drinking the energy
drink full throttle i was drinking like
one of those every hour just to stay
awake and i'd be like this jittery and i
wasn't even doing drugs back then thank
god the adrenaline's just gonna yeah
beat you down oh yeah
the highs and lows you have to find a
way to keep an even keel you know what i
mean you gotta otherwise it's just gonna
be otherwise you're gonna make a bad
move with a bad time and just yeah it
was the biggest bet you ever placed uh i
mean in in in the tournament it's just
one you know i mean it's a one-time
entry fee but i've played in games in
the world i've played some of the
biggest some biggest game in the world
where uh
in poker like some of the parts would be
upwards of 25 30 000
like for just for one you win that hand
you would you know you take down 20 30
grand
it would be big i mean there are bigger
games but it doesn't feel like you know
multi-millionaires and this went on for
how many years uh i played poker from
like i started playing when i was like
uh probably about 18 19
and i took i started playing
quite seriously through
like 2007 2008
then i got back into bowling again
because i was always a great bowler and
i started wanting the bowl again because
when michael bloomberg became mayor he
shut down all the underground clubs in
the city so now that means i had to go
to foxwoods where he could sign atlantic
city vegas to place to play poker and i
didn't really want to do that i couldn't
you know it's a lot easier driving 20
minutes to having to commute that far
every day so i kind of try to transition
back to boeing which i did
and i was always at one of the best
amateurs in the world in bowling so i
got back into that and started making
money bowling again
not not gambling on bullying but no but
there i mean no no there's still money
aspect and i i bowled for plenty of
dollars i have one of the most famous
bets in bowling i is this is a story
that is that i could nobody else in the
world has ever done what i did and
there's this one story that i did it was
in cincinnati during a huge tournament
that i had done and uh that like i said
it was me betting my own money betting
to i bet
i had bet and made money that i would
make a 710 split which is like one of
the most impossible split but i bet that
i'd make it uh four times out of a
hundred the odds of making it are
astronomical in the millions of people
like oh this kid can't make it that they
were going to cover any bet i made and
the bet was like twelve hundred dollars
that i would make four out of a hundred
and i
on the very first attempt out of they
started setting up the splits and the
very first attempt i made the first one
there was a crowd of like 500 people
watching me they went absolutely nuts
and then i uh i made the second one the
20 second shot i made the third one the
33rd shot
and uh
i was getting tired i was because i'm
throwing about 38 miles an hour a
bowling 16 pound bowling ball trying to
get the pins to bounce out to make it
and i'm getting exhausted finally i turn
around to this crowd of 500 people i
said when i made this bet in staten
island before i said i was good i made
it all i mean my final one on the 68th
try i said right now it's my 60th try i
said i'm taking this ball making despair
i'm going to bed sure enough i picked it
up boom boom boom spam made it clip got
my money 1200 what what what is your
what is the personality trait that you
have that
i'm loud obnoxious i i i'm
[Music]
very arrogant i guess into a way because
even bowling and poker if i lose if i
lost a hand i used to i'd scream [ __ ]
and be a bowling i'd kick the ball
return take my hat off my head throw it
across the thing you know take my rosin
bags right off the monitor i just i had
a very terrible attitude not bad
sportsmanship sure temper very short
temper oh my god the shortest
it's [ __ ] literally seriously as bad
like like a yosemite sand i would turn
beet red and want to just kill somebody
you get this from your dad yeah it is
for my dad my father had just as violent
temper with me if not worse
and did that get you into trouble as
well
i thought you know i've had some trouble
i'm not gonna lie but your gambling crew
you made money or you lost oh gambling i
definitely made money absolutely i
couldn't if i had if i definitely if i
have
to sit down and figure out how much
money i've actually made in my life it
would make me better how much i've blown
is another story but that's what i'm
saying so you've blown you lost a lot i
bought millions i couldn't tell you how
much so it when you stand back and look
at that what 10-year span
yeah you you came out ahead or
behind i did like i said i had material
possession at the time i had a lot of
material possessions to show for it you
know i was looking at my house
exactly car you know i mean i had and i
was still still going and still being
able to bowl i was on then when i was
bowling when i came back after the world
series of poker that one of the bowling
ball companies sponsored me
hammer so i was actually they would give
me all my equipment for free just to
bowl for their bowls and promote the
brand so i look i said my costs below
and i had i made money bowling plus i
was working at the time so like yeah i
was making money and i was still
gambling you know i mean poker was
always at that point was a good time in
my life
but i made i definitely made
millions of dollars and it's just
unfortunately
gone it's like when you gamble it's like
monopoly money you know i mean it
doesn't have real value it never does
i would always just i would get it in my
pocket it just it can't sit there i
can't stay there it was like the
expression that's burning a hole in my
pocket it literally was i'd have to go
out and do something and you know i mean
just go buy
a necklace or buy like a watch or buy a
new to get a truck or you know i mean
just do the oh listen you know what they
meant the playing in the metro playing
the diamondbacks in phoenix i never been
there let's go hop a flight and took a
plane to phoenix
my mother called me for bread that
monday night because joe can you bring
bread milk at some soda i'm like mom at
the mets games because yeah i know i'm
watching it i'm like no mom you don't
stand they met they're on the road in
phoenix you didn't [ __ ] tell me you
went to phoenix i thought you were
upstairs i'm like i'm sorry
i went to chief of metro playing at home
watching the game and i hear i am in
phoenix arizona that's how i was i just
want to do something i was impossible
how old are you now i am 40. are you
still gambling
no
so you're not gambling no how do you
turn that off
uh lack of income
lack of you know but i mean have you
found another vice
uh
right now i'm kind of not like i said i
try to
at this point i'm trying to uh you know
i'm on a better i think i'm on a better
path at this point i i think
i know i'm not really doing anything
crazy but i had a wild side but like
right now i think i'm on the street now
but you know it's one day at a time
that's all i can say because i don't
even know what tomorrow's going to bring
like i do know like you know i have
friends that if i get back into physical
shape that and i want to go bowl again i
have friends that are willing to put
money up to me to sponsor me in bowling
if i wanted to get back into play poker
i have friends that are willing to back
sponsor me and poker you know what i
mean but i need to get back to a good
mental spot you know you mean because i
i have burned bridges you know i mean i
have burnt some bridges and i just want
to get on the street now you know yeah
no now frankie told me that you're
dabbling in drugs as well yeah i have
i've had a lot i've done a lot of you
know drugs in my life
tell me about that
uh my space my started adobe stories
pretty much the
like if webster's dictionary had how you
get addicted to opiates same way as me i
got into a car accident doctor started
providing 10 you know perk tens to me
then he sent me to a pain management
doctor who unfortunately was corrupt
he said to me what do you want i said
isn't it supposed to be where you're
supposed to put me on a medicine not the
other way around
and at that point this is when the the
30 milligram oxycodone really became
popular you know
and i said give me 180 uh 30 milligram
oxycodone he goes oh the blues like he
didn't even call it as a doctor's name
he just called it as it was you know
this guy was illegally so he started
giving it to me and at first i was just
taking a one by one by one no problems
you know every month i'd had leftover
you know i mean like you know like a
normal person just taking that
prescribed when i bowled maybe next to
one
and then eventually i was born a
tournament one day in new jersey and the
last game i bought my back locked up i
was going for the first place first
place was like like ten thousand dollars
and one of my friends around i was like
joe you know if you break that pill up
and sniff it he's like
that'll it'll kick it even faster he
goes like i was wearing the dnf just you
know do not finish tournament i was like
i couldn't physically i was so much
agony i'm like i knew if i took one of
them take 40 minutes kick in i'm like
bro i'm like i've never sniffed anything
in my life i'm sniffing it now he's like
sniff it come on i saw he's like i'm
like sorry i'm like all right i'll try i
took two of them broke them up sniffed
them the last game in the tournament i
shot 300.
it was like the devil took over me i'm
like wow look at this i don't have to
wait 40 minutes i can do it 90 seconds
to feel better this is awesome
where have i been and after that i was
just ripping and roaring before i knew
it all side down every month i was
running out of my 30s early then you
know i mean i'm like i was going to the
street to buy them then i found somebody
who was selling their
script i i started taking them i started
buying them from him you know what i
mean before you it got worse and worse
and worse
you know until eventually i had a friend
who said to me joey goes you're making
all this money and you're blowing it
he's like why are you wasting spending
20 hours a pill when you could just buy
a bundle of hair i'm like bro i don't
shoot anything i've never not put a
needle in my arm you don't have to shoot
it you can sniff it oh yeah really it's
cheaper let's go try that and i created
that and i started you know started with
that you know i started one little by
little just started sniffing that and
that took over my life
have you been in love before yeah
how did that complicate your life drugs
uh drugs haven't ended everything yeah
my uh last girlfriend who uh i'm not
gonna
remain nameless
i was with her for four years and uh she
actually got her message in drug
addictions counseling
go figure while we were together
and she would wake up in the morning and
she would check my pupils first thing
you know and she would say to me this
and that you know look look look look
and eventually uh
got to a point where it became you know
it's near the drugs
and i said it's you of course you of
course you
and she's like every time you go to the
bathroom i don't care what you're doing
leave the door open check it you know
she didn't trust me she's like i don't
care if you're taking a [ __ ] you leave
the door open
and eventually i found you know i would
do the middle of night like
like i was in cleveland right right
before we broke up we were in cleveland
the bowl tournament and she found my
pocket i found she found a bottle of 30s
all like 150 of them
now cleveland in february if you don't
know is pretty cold
it's like 20 below there was tons of
snow on the ground she takes the bottle
of pills and throws them on the roof of
the bowling alley he says let's go back
to the hotel she goes if you want if you
want me to stay not fly home come let's
go to the hotel i said fine
i
took a couple ambien i had i'm
prescribed ambient because i have sleep
apnea i took out the couple of ambien i
squashed them up i put in her sprite
let her step in go to sleep she fell
asleep
i then snuck out of the hotel room went
back to the bowling alley as they were
closing i found the manager i said let's
tell them the story blah blah i said
i'll give you 200 dollars if you just
for going up there
now this is like 2 30 in the morning oh
my god i'll give you another 200 if you
find them
the guy
goes up there searching search and
searches because i know that tomorrow
morning i'm going to be in dopestick and
i and i won't be able to bowl and
hammer's sponsoring the tournament i
have to bowl so this guy's looking
looking looking after two hours and
following he finds him i was like oh
thank god so now he following it's like
4 45 in the morning i have to read the
bowling line at 7 15 the ball i ball i
bowl great the first set five games i'm
leading the tournament that night i come
back to both my second set of five games
and i see the manager the bowling alley
he goes how'd you do i said i'm leading
right now he's like oh high five it's
got his hand wrapped in bandages i'm
like what the what happened to you i'm
like you burn yourself because no i got
such a weird frostbite on both of my
hands it's like oh [ __ ] i'm like i'm
sorry man i had a guy gave him a couple
hundred dollars extra and i ended up
making like quite a few thousand dollars
that weekend and my girlfriend kept
saying to me see she goes you don't need
those toes the ball good i'm like yeah
you're right babe you're so smart but
little did you know that i was you know
drugged and go to sleep snuck back to
the bowling alley and paid the manager i
ended up paying him 600 just to find my
oxycodone on the roof
tell me what the connection is between
drug addiction and gambling addiction
it's uh
it's
just the uh
it's hard to explain it's just
it's just uh
when you're you know when you're
watching you if you're better if you bet
on if i bet on the giants like in the
giants and the patriots playing the
super bowl you know the giants were huge
other dogs even though i'm a giant fan i
bet them to win the game just to see
them score the game when you touchdown
the euphoria it's like the same thing as
you know getting high it's just
unspeakable listen it's you know you
think it's something that money can't
but like you can't buy a gambling win
it's just it's there's no greater
feeling in the world it's just trying to
find a way to
live your life an even kid where you
don't need those extraordinary highs to
make you you know figure that life is
worth living without it like you know i
mean to keep yourself on just an even
keel
it's tough i mean it's tough to do
because there's nothing like i said
there's no greater feeling you know sex
and you know
gambling and winning you know getting
high it's it's tough but you just gotta
what's what's your biggest fear
my biggest fear it's not dying now i
could care less about
uh
uh
it's kind of stupid but i'm be there's
nothing worse i'm claustrophobic
to like to the degree where
like
i i couldn't even explain it's that bad
like i won't go in an elevator i i can't
it's just too small as big as i am like
i will not be buried i will not be
buried i don't care who takes care of my
you know me when i'm done you know just
take me a garbage bag and throw me in
the ocean that's fine with me i don't
care i just do not want to be buried i
know cremate is fine but that means you
have to be in the box and burns i don't
even want to think of that either just i
like the mafia style throw me over the
bridge with some cement buckets that's
fine with me so uh did is has a drug
addiction kind of i mean it's it's
replaced the gambling addiction yeah i
definitely differ that's what happened
after
a little because little or little i was
playing in the last couple years i would
play poker and at the end of the session
i'd win and i'd call the dealer
immediately like i'd be walking out to
pokemon i would literally just gotten
paid let's say 15 seconds prior the
minute i walked out the door the door
closed i'd be on the phone with the
dealer hey where you at
oh you're in bed oh well it's 4 15 in
the morning that makes sense all right
i'm coming by oh it's better to be worth
it oh yeah yeah i wouldn't go like that
was the thing as i'd walk out the door i
couldn't wait the money was burning like
i said burning a hole in my pocket i
couldn't wait to find the deal didn't
matter where they were didn't matter i
would get on a train or drive or borrow
a car and just do whatever i had to do
just to get where i had to go
this addictive personality you have yes
yes i've heard that for many i've heard
that many professionals do you think
it's something you
inherited it's hereditary exactly i'm
just going to say my father you know i
think it's you know it's just my
father's the same way my father was a
full-blown drunk you know me he rest in
peace he was addict you know had an
addiction my father's mother same thing
my father's brother
uh
same he drank himself to death he
actually was stoned drunk and fell down
his backyard off two steps and fell down
his head wide open and died on the spot
uh unfortunately my sister
was also she also overdosed and died and
she was younger than me so like i said
it definitely runs in my family what's
been your lowest point in your life
i lost my mother
and my father on the same exact day six
years apart
october 25th 12 and 18. my mom was
second then a year after my mom i lost
my sister and i i'm the one who found my
mother i'm the one who found my sister
and i'm the one who found my it's not
the same but it's it's she was fair my
dog was 16 years i found her also dead
lying next to me when i woke up in the
morning it was that was true everything
was traumatic i had to find three
different dead bodies in my old in my
old house
in three different floors of the house i
got to the point where before i sold it
i didn't know where this i didn't know
where to go in the house there was no
place that i couldn't sit and didn't
think of what body i found where oh
yeah it's not it's it was great those
are definitely the lowest point
coming home to find my mother down face
first on the floors what were you like
in high school
i was a small kid i was uh i was i won i
was a new york city champion
uh bowling my junior year of high school
i was on have you ever had a regular job
yeah yeah a few times yeah i i mean
delivered pizza then i worked at macy's
uh picked up gambling early yeah well i
right yeah i was that about to happen
originally i was delivering pizza and
working at macy's both at the same time
but i was started after i would do after
the night ship i would go play poker all
night and make even more money than i
did in the two jobs that eventually led
me to quitting them between bowling and
poker i could make enough to hell with
this i don't need to do this and i just
that's what got me into doing that do
you believe in luck
yes there's definitely
but i do
there's definitely such a thing as luck
yes but eventually in poker the best
players will eventually rise from top
like i don't i didn't like when i played
poker did i have a losing day yep that i
have losing a week yep but at the end of
those first few months of the first few
years that i played i was always a
winning player at the end of the year
like i said i might have had a losing
day or losing week but at the end of it
i'd always was the winner as the winner
was the winner was the winner
what do you
want to be remembered for when you're
when you're gone
uh
i
i don't know unfortunately i feel like
my life has been a letdown
like i was i thought i was on the str
when i was on espn when i was 23 and
you know doing articles and sports
illustrated about me i had been on a
good morning america before that and
like you know i i've been on
and that was on espn for weeks was that
your highest point yeah that was when i
was 23 in 2005 it was definitely the
highest point and i thought i was on the
road to superstardom i thought i was
going to pick up a sponsorship from one
of these poco websites and just keep
making money and money and then in order
to empire downhill i would love to be
able to turn it back right around
because poker you can play at any age my
and i know like my mind is still sharp i
know that i can still play i would love
to be able to get back into it and just
keep it going get it going again because
i know i want to i want to win the world
series of poker before i die but you
have to stop using yes i yeah that is
that's what i'm doing right now i'm
trying to be i'm been working very hard
at it
would you call yourself self-destructive
absolutely yeah tough destructive oh
absolutely i'm i'm my own worst enemy
yeah that's a common thing for people
like you i think yeah
unfortunately that is true you're adhd
no i know i i shouldn't say i shouldn't
say no
but i i will say i have never been
tested how's that yeah
you have friends
yeah
absolutely
not as many as i used to but i you know
i i everybody i guess as everybody grows
up you have different sets of friends at
different points like sometimes things
don't happen you just kind of spread
apart like you know i have free but i
have friends that i've been friends with
forever that i can still text today and
they'll answer me like no problem and
they were when times were tough they'd
help me out you know but like i said
nothing happened you just you move on to
a new set of friends what's a better
high gambling or uh or drug opiates
gambling gambling's always the best
because how you know when you're going
by when you get drugs or you know when i
take my medication you know medications
you know exactly i knew exactly what i
was you know what you're getting you
know you mean
amazon would be the betting a football
game you don't know what the outcome's
gonna be and that's the that's the rush
you're like you know i mean you don't
know when my team was down 21 nothing in
the first quarter and i'm
punching holes in my wall my house and
then all of a sudden
you know with 13 seconds left in the
fourth quarter my team takes the lead
finally i'm going screaming in my
neighborhood the people calling the cops
i'm screaming so loud yet they don't
know i'm watching some meaningless
college football game on tv is it uh is
the high from gambling
is it about winning or is it about the
risk the adrenaline from the risk it's
about no it's about the winning it's
about winning 100 about winning like i
said there is no greater feel in the
world
what's your biggest regret
all the money i squandered
oh
if i would have just if i i'm not saying
i'm not saying you know not enjoyed like
some extent you can't be a gambler not
lose no exactly that's what i said i'm
i'm not saying that but there are plenty
of people who will gamble in like same
way i do and have some discipline and
have you know millions of dollars in the
bank if i had discipline i would have
millions of dollars do you develop a
really thick skin about losing i mean
like there's got to be days where you
just think man i really [ __ ] up today
yeah but you got to remember that like
poker bowling whatever it is it doesn't
matter what happened today tomorrow's a
new day yeah you know especially in
portland playing a tournament like the
world series once you're knocked out
you're knocked out you know there's
nothing you could do about that until
you played the main event the world's
poker main event the biggest tournament
yeah wait till next year to enter again
but
when it comes time to
like with poker playing a cash game or
something if i lose all you need to do
is more money to rebuy in you know i
mean and tomorrow either sorry today's
bad day whatever tomorrow's another day
you come playing twice what you lost the
day before
so every day is a new day it's a
stressful lifestyle it is that's why i
said it's a hard way to make it easy
living people like oh what do you do you
sleep till two o'clock in the afternoon
and go play poker for 10 hours you eat
takeout you you know hang out with
strippers you do this what kind of life
stuff who wouldn't want that yeah it's
stressful think about it when you have
you know pocket aces and they lose and
you lose three thousand on the on the
hand when you had the best hand and
everything went wrong in the last card
you know i mean there's nothing you
could do because the deal put out that
you know i mean there's nothing that can
happen people think oh yeah it's an easy
way yes it's easy it's real easy it's
you want to point your i don't have any
hair but you want to pull your [ __ ]
hair out
do you have kids no no kids
what would you say
joe is the most important lesson you've
learned in your life
don't trust anyone
being in the world i've been being the
worlds i've dealt you know
too many people just
it they'll just burn you
my mother used to say trust everyone and
trust no one
like you know try to be nice and
everything but just you still just at
the end of the day you can't trust
anybody you can't
and just you know people could swear up
and down this no i swear i'll pay you
back oh i swear to god i swear my kids i
swear on my mother i swear my father
but you know the end of the day
you know it's all on you it is it's just
people can do what they want people will
do whatever they want to need get that
fix
you know they're betting sports and they
get
you know bookie says that's it you know
it counts closely you settle up they
find another bookie uh if you owe money
to a drug dealer you either go out and
steal and rob or you go to another drug
deal and get credit
i've never gone out and stolen a car or
done anything like that thank god
what's your craziest gambling story
gambling story you gotta have a crazy
night crazy story
uh
hmm let's think i got a few of those
one of the craziest i would say is one
night i was in for playing poker in new
jersey with my buddy and uh
we were playing poker at a club in new
jersey and after afterwards i won a few
thousand dollars nothing big but
afterwards we went to we came back to
stand island and my friend like it's
like four o'clock in the morning on a
monday morning or like we went to a
diner
so we're going to dine it was sitting
there there's no one in it there's the
guy work at the front desk the waitress
the bus boy and me and him that's all
we're sitting there
and uh we're waiting for our food all of
a sudden some guy walks in shaved head
you know
white guy all of a sudden he's
my friend goes holy [ __ ] he's got a gun
and my friend ran to the kitchen the
waitress the bus boy went to the kitchen
this guy had a silver revolver pointing
against the guy said and he started
beating him over the head to open the
safe
and my instinct was at first you know
people think you'd fight a fight and i
said that's you know and i decided just
to go over there and i couldn't help
myself i couldn't stand there and watch
a guy get his head beaten so i went
right toward the place and now you know
i went over there and as the guy saw me
he turned and he just panicked and the
guy ran out of there and i knocked on
the other guy's hand luckily before he
shot me and uh the guy hopped in this
bright yellow lancer i'll never forget
that as long as i live and took off
and uh you know i
basically saved the met the guys had
life the manager and every time i went
in after that they always gave me free
food because most like my friend the
waitress everybody around to go high and
my instinct was to go right towards it
right to go run right toward it i guess
that's my lifestyle my my you know i
need the action that was that was the
best action i could get i didn't pay i
didn't have to pay for it you know what
i mean it was just just it was just me
did you have this personality when you
were a kid
uh yeah because in little in little
league when i would strike i would you
know i the first two three bats i get
three hits and a fourth at bat i'd
strike out i'd take my bat and throw it
300 feet
i would slammed it by brick might take
my hat the bat and smashed my helmet to
100 pieces i was thrown out of so many
little league games like people could
not believe it you're 11 years old you
shouldn't be telling your 35 year old
dumb i'm probably to go [ __ ] yourself
like you shouldn't be doing that no
matter how bad the call was
and i'm like well i understand i don't
know what to tell you sorry just my
story i am
wow
do you do do you wish your personality
was more more mellow more subdued more
no i just wish i wish i had more
discipline
because i love who i am and i've always
been funny my friends always love you
know all my friends love them and the
way i am and everything but i just wish
i had more discipline when it came to my
life
and money and certain aspects of it
for every for me
great quality there's always
there's there's a downturn to it of
course yes there's a positive negative
to everything yeah exactly and gambling
yeah of course you see that lesson
like i said there's no you know i like i
said i always loved the
the you know in competition i loved
when i bowled and like the first time i
bought 300 and you know i bought 300 so
many times i couldn't tell you like you
know accomplishments were always
important to me in the world series of
poker coming in 50th winning i won
another poker i won a couple of poker
tournaments in vegas you know
winning is just
it's just great and i love having the
trophies and you know the the accolades
but i just
it's just like i said i i don't know how
to explain it it's just
i need that i need that fill in my life
i need to i need a reason to say yeah i
was first i was this i did this i'm the
best
what are you proudest of in your life
i would say that world series of poker
was quite the thing because at one point
listen that trip
even though i went out to world series
of poker i went out there to play the
main event that year no matter what
that trip started off awful for me at
one point in that trip i was broke
and i ended up turning it all around
winning money and cash games and then
ended up winning the seat in the main
event and
you know turned that into a huge win you
know
i cashed for 173
880
that's that's the 50th place played
exactly and like i'm just saying that's
again that's my roller coaster of my
life that how at one point in that trip
i woke up in the morning and i couldn't
afford the 299 breakfast buffet
downstairs
and then a few days later you know i
have six figures to my name it's just
that's the way that's the way i live
and you like it that way i love it yeah
i love it
you get so emotionally how does i mean
it sounds like you have anger issues
that's understatement do you get
depressed or anxious or anything like
that
yes yeah i think that i take medication
with my anxiety my anxiety's really
terrible i i don't like to be in the
crowd of people i like to perform and i
love to be like i like i should have
been i always said to myself people said
i should have been like a you know
comedian like gone on stage like yes i'm
in a public place i just don't like i i
don't like i guess like i said uh
you know i don't like being in clothes i
don't like people around me it starts
giving me the heebie-jeebies i guess and
that's i just like to
i like to have my freedom be wide open
do you like the attention yeah i love it
that's that's another thing i'm an eagle
maniac
i always have been always will be
wherever i go no matter where i am i
always have some people have to know oh
that's joe stoneman yeah it's joe still
my ass stoneman don't worry
what do you what do you worry about
like just day by day like well right now
you know just money money yeah
i was working for a while but it just
you know i have i have lots of pain i've
been through a lot i had covert twice i
was hospitalized i've had half i had a
piece of my uh
a
big piece of my lung taking a pizza mask
taking out my lung last year in the
hospital
uh i had like i said the second time i
had covert i was you know i was on a
death door somehow i [ __ ] made
through it um i have screws on my hip
i've had so many surgeries some car
accidents and and bowling injuries
and you know it's just tough i just want
to
you know try to get like a lot of pain a
lot of agony but what's what's your goal
right now
where would you like to be in front i
like to be if i i like to have you know
i'd like to be
like to have money in my pocket not have
to worry about where my next meal is
coming from and i'd like to be just
starting to even keep having a good life
and settle down and what does that look
like is that is that a gambling no drug
lifestyle or is that a yeah
nine to five job yeah i'd like to be
able to play poker with no drugs which
will just be on you know whatever
necessary medications i need
and i'd like to just be able to play
cards and just you know make it i don't
need to be a multi-millionaire to be
successful i don't want to be happy
right now at this point i've come to
realize i don't need to be the fame and
fortune that espn has to bring me i
could play the underground clubs that
now that do exist again here and there i
can be happy bringing home a thousand
fifteen hundred a week you know off the
books it's it's decent living and that's
all you know that's all i want right now
i wanna be able to start building up a
nice little nest egg and you know not
have to worry about where the next meal
is coming from or what am i doing or
how's my money situation
do you enjoy that underground
hustler yeah i like i do because when
you go there like the game starts seven
o'clock every night so that kind of
coincides with when the baseball game
started
i love sports i can do game the only
gambling i feel safe doing now is my
fantasy baseball league you know because
you put up one amount of money for the
year and that covers you for the whole
year but gives you action every day
that's the only thing i can do safely
anything else betting day to day i would
just be out of control within because
the book you'll give me a limit for a
thousand dollars for the week and before
you know it i'll blow it through and
tell them extend me extend me extend me
and they will and they always do and i
just get so far out of control and i
don't want to go down that road again so
the only thing i do right now is playing
my fantasy baseball league and that's it
that's when you get the debt collectors
coming back exactly please i've had some
i've met so many of them in my life i've
hidden out in hotels on 109 in jersey
for weeks i only said the one story
about the gun in my mouth but i've
hidden from bookies plenty of times i've
hit it in hotels friends apartments
everything and i can't even go to
certain friends because people you know
some of these debt collectors knew me
and they know which friends i had so i
have to think outside the box you know
okay which friend don't they gonna put
me with all right i got it you know
people they think i'm i'm not i'm on the
outside or just not so i have to i'd
have to out think them that's gonna be a
terribly stressful lifestyle yeah it is
but again it was fun for a while you
know it was fun hiding out oh getting
you know eating cake out and living out
of hotels it's fun for a while but you
get it you're right it gets old real
fast
you know not you know you hear someone
in the hallway and you see lights under
the door you're like oh god here here
comes the shooting but like i said i
realized at a young age they're not
gonna shoot you it's not them this ain't
the movies
they just want their money
they might hit they might try to slap
you know they might try to slap you
around or whatever but when people saw
me and i mean i'm being six five 330
pounds you know they thought twice about
that
all right joe thank you so much for
sharing your story all right good luck
with everything all right thank you
you